the new comedy ghost it brings the
yellow else with Beverly Hills Cop
thrills and Ghostbuster chills okay well
she's talking again so that's that's
progress
it's one of this fall's most anticipated
comedies in there Craig Robinson and
Adam Scott or the paranormal team of
your dreams dynamic I like to call yep
ghost it premieres Sunday October 1st on
Fox your dad and I spent 15 years
together on the LAPD and he always told
me his dream was for you to go to
college 12 turn to page six elope [ __ ]
and if I hear that you haven't been
studying I'm gonna come see you myself
you understand you may sort of oh he's
going divorce
no she was abducted by aliens sweetie
okay I know you're thinking crazy
actually I was
why did you take us I'm very I'm your
kidnapper unfortunately that's all I can
say about that
that's not very fair is it I work for
the bureau underground we investigate
the paranormal and anything outside the
scientific realm this is a hidden-camera
show where's Alex Trebek I did Alex
Trebek have a hidden-camera show how did
I miss that I am captain the fray I am
not exaggerating when I say that the
fate of the entire planet may rest in
you know him hey sweetie what's up I'm
sorry did she just say the fate of the
entire planet she's talking to her
daughter yep she took the call
she's the rude one starting now you two
are working for the underground it all
leads to Water Bridge the nuclear power
plant we need to get you inside that
reactor I'm gonna send over two of my
best guys how's it going man this is one
of those this is a copy machine uh-huh
I'm more of a fax machine guy max two
fax machine guy that has a fax machine
in it this one yep that one right there
- and what since this is an all-in-one
wraparound I think that's more your
specialty maybe you should just go ahead
bro I'm gonna go no I want you to see
this Wow you will show me the respect I
got yeah I can't be here for this and
see that was great watch your face good
staying here cuz he certifiably nuts and
you might get me killed
I could've died in there oh I need a hug
want to go to an independent coffee
house and talk it out what's going on
over there let me up
I want to beat through the fit or just
like maybe redo that the other way
around
Wow
[Music]
guns and bullets and we are great I
repeat we are very very frightened I
can't believe you let me come with you
everybody what was the head yelling the
head should not have been yelling here
it's a good question
gentlemen welcome to the bureau
underground Congrats man Wow congrats to
you partner okay you just called me
partner
[Music]
you
you